c'était un amoureux de sa région et du
général de gaulle ses premières armes
la plume et le stylo dans les années 60
jean françois bazin est embauché en tant
que journaliste dans un quotidien local
les dépêches de dijon il deviendra
rédacteur en chef de l'hebdomadaire la
lettre de bourgogne jusqu'en 2003 mais
la région se souvient surtout de l'homme
politique
docteur en droit il préside le conseil
régional de bourgogne
d'avril 1993 à avril 1998
il sera aussi l'associer de robert
poujade à la mairie de dijon
de 1995 à 2001 un premier adjoint qui
tentera de devenir mère mais qui perdra
face à un édile de gauche françois
rebsamen
et puis jean françois bazin restera
également dans les mémoires des
bourguignons comme l'écrivain qu'il
était passionnément devenu amoureux des
vins de sa région mais aussi de son
histoire
il est l'auteur d'une trentaine
d'ouvragés
[Applaudissements]